it's just it's insane but there's a lot
of women out there that do it and it's
very inspiring to me and we're rocking
it out pink is literally the best and
now making her even better she's coming
to make it Merkel's defense oh I have no
filter
the singer tweeted that she's happy to
see people standing up for Meghan quote
the way people treat her is the most
public form of bullying I have seen in a
while it's out of control
let's all be a bit kinder huh let's show
our children that it's cool to be kind
here's a little bit of backstory Meghan
and Prince Harry came under fire after
details of a recent family vacation came
out in British tabloids people just
couldn't understand why they were taking
private jets when they do so much
environmental advocacy guys really one
recent trip was for Megan's birthday a
source tells et they spent six days
celebrating her 30th birthday in Ibiza
quote arriving by private jet to steer
clear of the paparazzi I never thought
my life would be that awesome Elton John
was the first to defend Megan and Harry
after it was revealed the pair stayed at
his home in Nice he says the press
surrounding them was distorted and
malicious and may note that Megan and
Harry's flights have been carbon neutral
he also added quote Prince Harry's
mother Diana Princess of Wales was one
of my dearest friends I feel a profound
sense of obligation to protect Harry and
his family from the unnecessary press
intrusion that contributed to Diana's
untimely death she could walk into a
room of people and make them feel as if
everything was great of course
Elton famously performed candle in the
wind at Princess Diana's 1997 funeral
for now before
[Music]
[Applause]
he also attended Harry and Megan's royal
wedding in 2018 and performed at the
reception I think that's so happy I know
they're so happy all right guys what do
you make of this whole situation is the
press too hard on Megan and Harry did
you like pink and Elton John's responses
let's talk and for all the latest on
your favourites labs keep it locked to
all things et until next time I'm Katie
Krause and bye for now